it's october halloween season
and the time is ripe for a murder
mystery murder most foul except this one
takes place with a special twist
it involves the space program the apollo
missions
everyone's favorite space guitarist
major tom himself commander chris
hadfield
and this is a phenomenal interview i
know you're gonna love it i know you're
gonna love this book it's tough to do an
interview about a fiction book without
giving away too many spoilers so i'll
just refer you to these quotes from
folks like james cameron and from greg
hurwitz author of orphan x
as well as andy weir past guest on the
show
the author of the martian an exciting
journey into an alternate past
and of course
the quote from
our friend james cameron
is
not to be missed a nail-biting thriller
this is a smash hit
from commander chris hadfield i'm so
honored to have him on the show we
talked about his past books his
children's book his uh book previously a
non-fiction book as well as the apollo
murders which is just a delightful
nail-biting thriller appropriate for
halloween season so sit back enjoy this
blast off to the past the apollo
programs to the moon and beyond
and hopefully solving a nail-biting
murder mystery along the way
with our friend
commander chris hadfield come along
let's go into the impossible any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
today it is my great uh pleasure and
honor to be talking to commander chris
hadfield who has written numerous books
we're going to talk about all of them at
some point or another uh but his latest
book is a work of fiction hard science
space fiction it's not science fiction
it's hard science and it's fiction and
it's a murder mystery so this is our
first murder mystery uh commander we've
had on uh andy weir who endorsed your
beautiful book um as well and it's
always a challenge commander as you
might realize when i talk to non-fiction
authors i can talk all day about the
book
but when you talk to fiction authors how
do you do it so you don't have any
spoilers and i just want to get one
spoiler out of the way okay um
luke skywalker is princess leia's
brother okay let's just get that totally
out of the way commander so that the
sport unfortunately that has very little
bearing on the apollo murders
oh i must have read the wrong book so
we're talking about the apollo murders
which is a murder mystery set uh on
earth in russia on the ocean yes there
it is so we're going to do the thing
chris that no one is expected to ever do
which is to judge a book by its cover
tell me commander
what is the origin of the title
and the
cover art on this wonderful new book the
origin of the title is in fact the
origin of the book itself in that um a
publisher that i'd worked with on my
previous books who i really respected
and uh like him as a person he said i
think you could write a fiction book and
i've got a title the apollo murders what
do you think
and
it's so defining because apollo well
it's got to be you know in the late 60s
early 70s and murder has an s on the end
so there has to be at least two people
murdered in the book so that was very um
bound setting very defining of the book
itself but because it's a murder mystery
i wanted the book to look uh
compelling and space i've done two space
walks
the velvety infinite blackness of space
itself
is
so provocative when you're outside on a
spacewalk you swear you could reach out
and somehow get some of that eternity
onto your hand um and so i wanted the
book to reflect the contrast between the
surface of the moon
and
the depth of the blackness but also the
human in the middle and and the little
lunar lander um is such a tiny little
outpost
and and representative of the earth in
the background so when the graphic
artists working at it was our american
publisher came this is a suggestion i i
just thought it had the dripping portent
of a murder mystery but also
extremely factually accurate with a
small ship and heading down to the
surface of the moon so so i'm really
pleased with it and uh
and it just rekindles in my mind's eye
uh what it was like to be outside on a
spacewalk uh in in the depths of our
solar system itself
so funny because you mentioned in an
interview i watched uh recently that
space flight is joyous space flight is
is miraculous space flight is is
titillating in the best way and yet now
it's it's ominous it's foreboding this
cover of this book you know it you built
me up that space flight is this thing we
should all aspire to like our friend uh
william shatner will be doing tomorrow i
i've had the honor of being in a tv show
with him called unexplained and uh i'm
wondering you know first of all what
what makes space flight so joyous you're
my fourth uh sorry you're my sixth
astronaut that i've interviewed on the
into the impossible podcast you're the
second male astronaut so i've
interviewed four including one jessica
myer dr jessica meyer while she was on
the iss your former home we're gonna
talk a lot about that and your five
months there sojourn but what makes
space flight joyous i would think it
would be you know a mixture of of poor
tent a fear of of this ominous threat of
danger outside the few millimeters that
separate you from utter death
well then you you fall victim to the
same uh illusion that so many movie
makers do and even songwriters you know
where
where uh
space oddity or rocket man they're
really just metaphors for loneliness
number one
it's magic you are weightless
it is just so fun to be weightless you
have an instantaneous superpower with
just the touch of a toe or a finger you
can fly effortlessly forever
so that's
that's just a hilarious joy and
um
every time you float past a window or
stop and look the entire world is
rolling by in just unbelievable
three-dimensional
multi-colored multi-textured majesty
beside you and it's mesmerizing and
silent and and uh unavoidably uh you
know omnipresent and so you're seeing
and learning and understanding the whole
world like the same sort of feel you
have for your hometown
and and then the underpinning all of
that is you're doing something
exquisitely hard but because of the
life's work that brought you there and
all the preparation and study and
self-change you're doing it well
and there's a real intoxication in doing
something you know it's like making that
masterful chest move or or doing
something on a skateboard properly for
the first time or whatever there's a
great delight of self-discovery when you
have mastered something that previously
you know like the first time you
actually rode a two-wheeler and no one
was holding onto the seat behind you
there's a great freedom and joy to doing
something complex and doing it well and
in space all three of those things are
constantly weaving in amongst each other
and you're there with great people
capable people and so it's uh it's a lot
of fun but when you're writing a murder
mystery some of those people have to be
um not what they seem and also
you know earth politics and earth
military objectives and such they often
you know intrude their unwelcome heads
into the joyous human experience of
being in space so it's a really ripe
field to write a murder mystery
but at the same time it gave me a lot of
freedom to write about just what it is
like at a personal level to be amongst a
crew chatting and talking and reveling
in in the experience itself yeah it
seems like you know from your upbringing
we want to get into that and one of the
things that's most resonant to me in my
six interviews now with astronauts is
the one um kind of medium that they
always seem to convey is coachability
which sounds strange because dr scott
parazynski your fellow a crewmate uh
that you uh were you know in your famous
incident in space which we're gonna get
to your medical incident in space that
that he was a part of of that experience
um he's just an amazing human being
and yet he feels like he has so much to
learn still and it made me think uh
commander um have you have you heard of
this notion of the hedonic treadmill
have you ever heard that notion not the
space treadmill but the hedonic
treadmill i don't i don't know those two
words next to each other no
so it's basically like where do you go
from here commander you've done
everything you wanted to do since you
were nine years old uh you've you've
conquered great heights you've been in
space where you know there are fewer
people in the in that have been to space
than are in the nba basically right uh
fewer that have won the nobel prize et
cetera et cetera so i want to ask you
where do you go from here is it is there
a chance of a letdown because you had
that peak experience the treadmill is
just like where do you go you can't go
anywhere you know from my perspective as
a father as a as a parent as a scientist
as a pilot
i can't think of a better experience
what are you hoping to do next so to
speak i think you're trying to interpret
uh how my life looks
obviously from the outside and not how
it looks from the inside and i i do i
see every single day as a peak
experience and you know i i've was in
the delivery room as my wife gave birth
to each of our three children over the
years and
you know i i'm training a new puppy
right now which is just so much fun and
um you know
i i've in the last year learned how to
write a thriller novel and
um
i got to drive a really high performance
car last week with a super expert and
just see what it's like to be a
professional race car driver and
and all of those to me are just a
glimpse into the wonders that constantly
surround us and
i've flown in space so yeah it's not
like my life was some humdrum you know
boring and all of a sudden i was in
space and then i was back again and i
was doing it to impress someone or
something it's the opposite this is just
one of the amazing manifestations
of
opportunity that has come along during
my life and
and uh so many of them have occurred
prior to me flying in space and then in
between space flights i served as an
astronaut for 21 years i was only in
space for six months so 20 and a half
years of service um to allow other
people like like jessica and other
people you mentioned
to
succeed and do what we're all trying to
do in space even leading to the tourist
flying that's going on right now and
then all the things i've done since then
you know teaching university running a a
space technology incubator chair of the
board of a lunar settlement
uh and lunar law foundation and you know
working with all sorts of businesses
all of it
is of a set piece for me and i'm
and there are so many things i don't
know anything about you know i'm just
i'm just a novice at almost everything
in the world i'm really good at a few
very specific things but but most of the
world i'm just an infant and and to me
that's that's how i treat everything
it's how scott you know that's how i
think if there was one and maybe you
you've already uh
noticed it speaking to the other five if
there was one defining astronaut
characteristic it's a perpetual
dissatisfaction with their level of
competence
they don't want to rest on their laurels
they don't want to think i did one thing
i'm done
you know it's more like uh wow i've done
a thousand things and they have allowed
me to see a million things so i'm going
to keep doing other stuff that opens the
world to my understanding and
comprehension and appreciation
i guess yeah the question of how to top
it was answered by uh apollo commander
neil armstrong uh do you know what he
did after he got out of the nasa
uh service business commander uh he did
a lot of different things he was a
professor and he that's right ran a few
businesses and he
worked with uh a lot of students and
yeah neil did a lot of things in the
restaurant that's why i always say i
have the best job in the world because
it's the job that neil armstrong thought
was
only possible to top going being the
first human on the moon
i did talk to nicole stott um last week
her book is coming out tomorrow she
sends regards uh she wants your book to
be number one not uh in fiction and hers
to be number one in non-fiction and i
hope that will be the case i hope she's
not just just right over here in fact
yeah
yeah she's an amazing soul she's a
two-time guest on the show and um and
she told me she never feared really for
herself she feared for her son and she
has just one child and and she was
multiple times
in space on the space station etc um you
talk a lot about fear being kind of a
product of byproduct of irrationality of
not going through in a logical rational
way and yet you must recognize your
phone and combat missions uh there are
people that you know would come
afterward are still alive hopefully and
that will be alive for a very long time
did you ever have any fear like she did
in terms of not yourself but for other
people that would have to grapple with
some decisions that you made
something i learned from my wife many
many years ago
was that
if you allow your fears
to restrict the choices and activities
of the people that are important to you
that has negative consequences
you know if if you say no you can't do
that thing that's really important to
you because i'm afraid of it
or because if it doesn't go the way you
want then it might you know might have
negative consequences for me
you know it everything has to be within
reason but at the same time
um denying someone else their dreams
that has a cost
and
and so if nicole for example had said
well chris and i are raising roman now
and therefore i'm going to give up on 80
of the things that i wanted to do with
my life
i mean it would take a pretty super
human uh set of values to to not then
recriminate to some degree or
or begrudge and it's okay when things
are going well but if things don't go
well you know how do you balance all
that out and so what my wife helena and
i have done and we've been together
since uh high school we met in a high
school play i met her when she was 14
and i was just 16. um
is
uh support each other's dreams and
enable them wherever we can you know we
were i was a government employee for 35
years so we never had much financial
freedom
but
always wherever possible and and it's
never going to be perfect but allow the
other person to pursue the things that
are really important to them
otherwise
uh you are the part of life that is the
millstone or or the or the obstacle to
what's really important to them and so
yeah um
and it switches your role around so yes
what i really want to do has risk
everything worth doing in life has risks
whether it's psychological financial
reputational or or life or limb
the real question is
how do you decide which risks are worth
taking and then once you've decided this
yeah i know there's risk but you know
getting married or learning to drive a
bike or or flying a rocket ship or
climbing everest or or becoming a
professional artist yeah there's a big
chance of failing at all those things
but it's important enough to me that's
something i'm going to do then your job
now
is a risk manager your job is not to
hope or to rub your rabbit's foot or
something your job now
is to on behalf of yourself and the
program and your loved ones is to do
this thing as well as you possibly can
so that you have optimized your chances
to succeed as best that you can and to
me that's the very essence of of
personal commitment to it but also of
how to maintain that relationship with
the people that are around you and that
are important to you
so this book the apollo murders uh
covers a fictitious mission that could
have happened if it wasn't cancelled for
budgetary overrun you know it's funny
commander as i'm sure you know the
budget for nasa is lower than the u.s
spends on lipstick every year not to say
lipstick isn't valuable right but to
think about canceling it you know when
we're talking about trillions of dollars
kicked around like they're you know uh
like they're almost nothing um it was
canceled for lack of funding um to what
extent do you think if the mission had
taken place that we the incremental cost
in other words you know what is the
return on investment or what was the
return on investment of the apollo
missions after the first few as as we
know were were quite uh captivating for
the public but after that seemed like
the public lost a little interest
well to say apollo 18 or apollo 19 or
apollo 20 and 21 were cancelled for lack
of funds is incorrect they were they
were canceled for lack of political will
obviously the money was there they just
decided no i will spend it on something
else instead of this you know
look at what the dod's budget is you
know compared to what it actually cost
um so benefit i think that's really
worth talking about um
in the 10 years after the apollo program
there were more phds per capita in the
us than any time before any time since
yes people saw themselves differently as
a result of what the example that the
apollo program said we also learned the
fundamental history of the earth itself
where did the moon come from and when
and and how does a system like this even
work you know
just the straight um self-awareness of
our own history and therefore being able
to propagate that out into the future
the picture that bill anders took
around christmas of 68
and
on apollo
8
and they have a lovely logo for their
flight because it's circle around the
earth circle around the moon and come
back it makes this lovely figure eight
but as he was coming in
as he was coming around the back or the
infinity symbol yeah as he was coming
around the back side of the moon and he
grabbed his hasselblad and took a
picture of the earth popping into view
that's the first time humanity had ever
seen their whole planet
in in proportion as one little
unbelievably rare and precious blue
jewel in an eternity of empty blackness
and
that sparked a huge
uh revelation of self-awareness
how finite it is this earth is just a
spaceship the whole earth catalog and
greenpeace and the earth um you know
sustainability and and uh
all of those ideas
right all of those ideas were the child
of our capability to change our
perspective if if you're an aunt someone
you know a little ant ant somewhere on a
hillside in san diego your world is very
small you know but it's really important
to you but
your actions are are local at best and
tiny and
but human beings can become because of
our collective decision making
so much more
influential than ants and so much more
um
uh future shaping than ants
but if all we ever think about is our
particular little ant hill and the the
tiny you know how tall are you you know
two meters tall you know you're the the
the tiny amount of the world that you
can see from two meters above the
surface um
if that's limits your thinking then it's
going to radically limit your ability to
make good decisions about the future and
what travel to space whether it's
robotic with all of the sensors that we
have up now they're measuring and
teaching us about the world and
communicating or whether it's just the
straight
human perception of our world and the
reality of it to me
and what we learned about our own planet
the ecology of it how it actually
functions as a system how does it react
with the energy from the sun what is the
balance of energy in and energy out and
why do we still have an atmosphere when
mars is mostly gone and venus boils it
to above the temperature of lead just
trying to get an accurate picture of
ourselves to me that yeah sure there's
lots of technical stuff you know
integrated circuitry and then what has
led to gps and all the other things we
take for granted um
but to me self-awareness and and
understanding to a slightly better
degree our place in history and our
place in the universe that's the real
lasting legacy of the apollo program
and indeed edgar mitchell i think was
the apollo 16 he he had this famous
quote he said you develop an instant
global consciousness he's talking about
the earthrise photo um that you
mentioned an intense dissatisfaction
with the state of the world and a
compulsion to do something about it from
out there on the moon international
politics looks so petty you want to grab
a politician by the scruff of the neck
and drag him a quarter million miles out
and say look at that you son of a bee
um
but but commander if we need to take a
politician out there
i mean how many people yeah now there's
you know commercial civilians are going
to william shatner's going up today um
uh and i i wonder if
that quote kind of depressed me because
to think that you have to you can't
visualize it you actually have to
physically go there come on i mean what
hope is there for humanity if the only
way to get traction to get buy-in is to
actually experience what you and so few
have experienced
if um
if you're willing to blame the ills of
the world on the current elected crop of
politicians you will never solve
anything
and think how bad the last politicians
were or the ones before that or the ones
before that or all the way back to you
know george washington who's now uh you
know either a hero or a scapegoat
depending on what you want to blame uh
for events in history you know people
are hugely imperfect and our elected
officials
they're they're just a uh
often well-minded but slightly
narcissistic subset of the rest of
society and it's really nice and
convenient to blame someone else because
it absolves you of responsibility
what is necessary in changing the world
is for individuals to put a
responsibility on their shoulders
in reality our political leadership is a
reflection of our electoral process and
therefore of our individual will that's
the beauty of democracy
and in in fact i lived in russia for
five years
the the leadership that they have isn't
there because it was a military junta
that that did a coup and rested control
of the country no that's
kind of according to that type of
culture and the thousand-year history of
what was you know russ tribes and their
tribes in the soviet union and russia
that's the type of leadership that they
think suits them
so if we want to change the world it has
to be
at the individual awareness level and
sure you've got to work the short term
stuff and you've got to work the process
and you've got to work regulation and if
we're going to truly deal with the the
pollution that is uh changing the
climate of the planet then you know you
can't just wait 50 years but at the same
time uh it's so easy just to sit at the
bar you know like like in cheers and
norm just or whomever just
or probably i think uh the the bar
characters in um in the simpsons are
more representative where all you do is
grouse about the world and then and
blame it on whatever big pharma big
business politicians and then you can
just do whatever you want because it's
not your responsibility right and so
when ed mitchell was saying those things
he's trying to make a point
but uh
the reality of it is
um our world is so
unbelievably generous
and tough as nails when i was on board
the space station for half a year
think what happens in half a year you go
from one side of the sun to the other
you go halfway around our solar system
and in that time i got to watch winter
and summer swap ends on the world i got
to watch the world take essentially it
occurred to me at the time it took a
breath
out of four and a half billion breaths
and that was so
optimism-building for me how incredibly
tough this planet is is and and the fact
to know that life we found fossils from
almost four billion years ago here in
canada and down on the northern shores
of australia
life has been on this planet
uninterrupted for four of the four and a
half billion years so the earth is tough
and life is tenacious we talk about oh
we're destroying the earth
we couldn't kill all the earth all the
life on earth if we give it our absolute
best shot light has withstood so much
worse than us that's right but quality
of life
and improved quality of life for our
species and a sense of responsibility
for the sustainability of all life on
the earth that is something that we can
put on our own shoulders and that is our
real objective and that's what everybody
needs to pay attention to and sure you
can wrestle some current elected
official out there but they're just on a
two-year term or a four-year term and
then they've got their own problems um
it's really up to each of us with our
improved self-awareness and that's why i
think it's kind of cool that this summer
for the very first time and it's hugely
imperfect at this point but tourists are
starting to see space
you know we've got the completely all
messed up right now and and it's still
really early days but it's the start of
something really significant and we need
that perspective to influence our
thinking individually
and collectively absolutely so reminder
we're talking with commander chris
hadfield famous for many many things and
deservedly so but this time author of
the apollo murders doing the impossible
on into the impossible we'll get to sir
arthur c clarke's influence on commander
hatfield in just a bit but i want to
point out that i was incredibly
impressed by all the hard science of
this of this work of fiction again it's
not science fiction and science fact uh
but with a fictional twist that most of
the characters in this book uh took
place and actually chris you might be
pleased to learn the lunakod which plays
a role in apollo murders was discovered
by my colleague professor tom murphy who
bounces lasers off from new mexico to
the moon's surface to the retro
reflectors left by your colleagues your
predecessors um and also the luna cod
rover and so a lot of uh a lot of
excitement was found he's trying to
measure the distance to the moon to one
millimeter accuracy to test einstein's
theory of general relativity but anyway
this is really hard science so you in
into great detail not only in the
characters you know the more famous ones
but uh i couldn't believe that you know
some of the characters were actually
real people i mean i'm a space geek and
and so forth but that you got down to
the you know the exact caliber of the
pistols that the soviets would carry
i want to mention something that i find
resonant between you and scott dr scott
parazynski which is that you both credit
the apollo program for your dedication
devotion and love of space and desire to
become an astronaut overcoming just
literally astronomical odds
the apollo missions had a plaque at
least the first one did that said we
came in peace for all mankind now again
this is a murder mystery set in and i
don't want to make it out that you know
who's the villain we're not going to
spoil anything but um do you think they
they really achieved that or was this
kind of a way of you kind of working
through fan fiction what really was the
underlying tenor of that time it wasn't
all about peace and love of all mankind
it was about global domination and
showing technological prowess and you
did the russians did a great job and the
us did a better job um but talk about
that how influential was getting the
politics and the and the the emotions
the uh
the environment of that time it was so
gripping to me and i wasn't that old i
was only you know three years old when
this book takes place how did you work
on that was that visceral to you because
you you remembered it or did you have to
do a lot more kind of historical
political global geopolitics research
than than you might expect i love
learning things and i love researching
things and so in writing the apollo
murders i
dug so deeply into
the apollo program the nasa space
program but also the the soviet space
program at the time and
the things that were actually going on
uh you know the secret soviet space
station that was spying on the world
that no one knew about at the time at
least on this side of the atlantic and
how that was discovered and how it in
and as you say i would say 90 of the
things that happen in the apollo murders
are real and over half of my characters
are real people so that made it so much
fun to write and interweave um
but uh
that space station which was called
diamond in in russian that's almas almas
mysteriously malfunctioned and and came
apart in the spring of 73 and luna that
you mentioned the soviet rover that was
investigating things on the moon it
mysteriously malfunctioned and died on
the surface of the moon in the spring of
73. so when i was putting together the
plot i was thinking wow these two real
world events provide a lovely framework
for maybe a potential idea of how i
could put this together and the huge
soviet geopolitical frustration with
their inability after having had won the
race to space with sputnik and then the
first human being in space with gagarin
first woman in space with valentina
tereshkova the first spacewalk with
alexa leonov they were off to a flying
head start
but their rockets weren't good enough
and the n1 rocket was this huge
uh cash cow that was never going to work
and the frustration of the competing
camps that's a really interesting story
and my character the main character in
there uh cela may
that's a real guy who was the competing
camp and if he'd been allowed to make
the decisions then the soviets may have
won the race to the moon and i knew
alexa leonov really well he was their
designated neil armstrong he was the one
that was going to walk on the moon i've
been inside the landing
ship that he was supposed to pilot down
to the surface if they just could have
got their rocket right and what was
going on within american politics
you may or may not know um but brian
when the space shuttle under nixon was
being funded in its early days nixon
had you know with watergate and with the
winding down of um
of the vietnam war obviously he wanted
to put budget somewhere else and he
didn't have enough budget for the space
shuttle so he gave a bunch of the of the
decisional authority to the department
of defense to the u.s air force and they
got to design a large part of the space
shuttle and the design profiled and the
papers were just declassified very
recently the design profile of the
shuttle was to launch out of california
towards the north pole
open the payload bay doors do a fast
space walk grab a soviet satellite you
know a spy one plunk it inside close the
doors and land all in in a hundred
minutes
that was
a design criteria for the space shuttle
and so when the soviets haven't have a
copy called
when you look at the apollo murders i
think it becomes a lot more credible how
nixon decided to fund apollo 18 and what
the mission design of apollo 18 would
have been and you know james cameron
wrote a lovely
thing on the back but he said a
desperate apollo mission that never
really happened
or did it
and i love that james jim wrote that
because he loves this book and and um
and and you know and had a couple really
good ideas when i was talking to him he
had a couple clever tiny little plot
tweaks that improved
last spring
so yeah um interweaving it with reality
for me
you're right it's not science fiction
it's alternative history fiction with
just what might have happened
i love it yeah it reminded me of a
totally different genre but uh kim
stanley robinson is a ucsd graph um he
has a book called galileo's dream which
is also like an alternative history and
things that happened to galileo and his
time travel et cetera et cetera but this
book the viewers apollo murders is chock
full of really just stuff to geek out on
i just loved it so it reminded me of
andy weirs the martian
you know another ucsd he didn't graduate
though he he dropped out but i think
he's gonna have a decent career chris
yeah i love andy and um
you know a couple things about andy i i
was lucky enough to read an early
version of the martian and uh and make a
recommendation on the cover of that one
and so that's nice and andy you know
uh and i really like his new book
project hail mary it's a great fun read
and in fact the narrator for project
hill mary ray porter is also the
narrator for the apollo murders and he
does it so well you're gonna love a
couple details that ray porter snuck in
that could only be sort of
um visible or or audible when you listen
to it because they didn't end up in the
way that i wrote it so so that's a
really nice surprise yeah the other
thing about the other thing about andy
where he's such a sweet and thoughtful
and and
not not astronaut kind of guy at all you
know when he was coming to the johnson
space center for the first time he
actually considered
did he have to fly because he was quite
afraid to fly he was going to like take
the bus or the train all the way from
california to houston just so he could
avoid the risk and the fear of flying
and yet he writes such a beautiful
insightful book like the march it's
amazing that you yeah
big respect for andy yeah he he was on
the show to promote you know project
hail mary and we're friends uh you know
from from ucsd connections but he
admitted that during that time when he
was invited to houston he went to see us
a therapist and i'm on the show i'm not
telling stuff you know a secret of but
he said the therapist said i'll give you
some pills you know see xanax or
whatever so you can take the flight but
you have to deal with your crippling
depression when you get back and it was
it was so vulnerable and so on he just
went into like i had this tremendous
depression for many years and and
conquering that was kind of the key to
getting over fears of flying and other
fears that manifest himself in other
ways i love that this book apollo
murders gets into the to the uh to the
personal lives of the psycho drama
that's taking place when you go through
through an astronaut type program again
it's very challenging to talk about a
work of fiction uh but i'll just say if
you love the martian if you love project
hail mary and all my listeners do
you have to get the apollo markers it
was exactly i listened to the audiobook
i got an advanced copy of the written
book get them all get all versions that
you can possibly get and support
commander because this particular work i
think in my mind it left a little bit
opening to uh to maybe a sequel i don't
know maybe maybe not maybe i'm just
crazy but you should know that there's
an astronomy fiction you know work that
i'm working on which is i don't know if
you know but the james webb space
telescope the successor to hubble is
going to be shipped from uh to through
eventually go around to be launched uh
you know in in the in the coming months
and it's the most expensive thing ever
to be shipped and i don't think it's
it's you know it's seven billion dollars
just the hardware and that's a 30
billion dollar project but i don't think
it's being guarded by like an aircraft
strike you know group or whatever so i
think that would be kind of like space
pirates but on on c anyway i don't need
to give you ideas i want to ask you
something
answer to um question uh i'm already
working on on the next book in the
series so yeah is there gonna be a movie
commander um lots of movie houses have
come and talked to us already but the
last thing i want is is another bad
space movie with this time though with
my name on it so where i'm in no hurry
to make a bad space movie if we're gonna
make this into a movie i want it to be
one that i can be proud of you don't
want it to be armageddon too commander
oh or or space cowboys or or gravity or
something you know i i i wanted you know
to be more like from the earth to the
moon or apollo 13 where they really
worked hard to um you know to tie it to
reality so that you don't just insult
and belittle and and uh
and sort of puzzle people
with what you didn't bother even
researching
i want to ask you um i want to be
respectful of your time but but i'll
take all i can get from you sir but um i
in your in your memoir and astronauts
guide to life on earth you talk about
this stress that you endured going
through all these psychological exams
and so forth and and one phrase really
stood out to me you said um how does how
can i stand out yet not be a jerk
what do you mean by that commander
[Music]
when you go through astronaut selection
right now in the american and the
european astronaut selections on the
order of 20 or 30 000 people are
applying for a handful of jobs
so if you're going to get hired you have
to stand out i mean what is remarkable
about you because if you're unremarkable
then you're going to not going to get
picked and obviously you need to have
qualifications
but even if you say okay they have to
speak three languages they have to have
at least a master's degree and they have
to have a thousand hours piloting
command of an airplane well out of 30
000 people that's still going to be 500
people and they're you know so so how do
you stand out and obviously one way is
to make a big noise about yourself you
know and
and
you know trumpet yourself and and
promote yourself and and uh
and
that's not a very canadian thing to do
but also i think it's a self-defeating
thing to do you
you don't want someone on a space
station
who needs to trumpet themselves in fact
it's it's the opposite that you want you
want someone whose entire purpose is to
make everybody else their best
someone who's got both the competence
and the confidence to put themselves
into that position so it's it's quite a
strange role to be competing for the job
of an astronaut when it's maybe against
your nature to be like blowing your own
horn and and so i
i thought about it every day i just
decided okay i'm going to be myself
i'm obviously going to mention all of
the strengths and all the things that
i've done just so that they don't
inadvertently not know that you know i
used to be a downhill ski racer or
whatever in case that helps them with
their decision making
but i want them to have a frank accurate
assessment of my own skills and and not
just some overblown you know tinder
version of who i am so um so uh so yeah
it was it was a bit of a tightrope to
walk and
it lasted for months and months and
months and there was no feedback and i
just i felt like i was just so out of
control and
and crossing my fingers and hoping and
it was an enormous relief when the phone
on the wall rang and the the president
of the space agency called and said
would you still like to be an astronaut
because that was a watershed moment
after all of that uh lifetime of
preparation and then nerve-wracking
handwriting and waiting
okay uh so let's see i have uh
several more questions if you'll indulge
me but i want to be respectful of your
time so let's go with rapid fire answers
then rapid fire uh do astronauts or did
the apollo astronauts carry suicide
options with them
everybody always has suicide options
with them you have them right now not
specifically that that's that's way down
the list of concerns okay do you still
think 2001 uh by the namesake of the
center that i am honored to be associate
co-director of uh arthur c clarke do you
think that is still your favorite pick
for best movie of all time space movie
of all time uh absolutely it is so
thought provoking and so much deeper
than just a space movie um
and based on a great book and kubrick's
cinematography great movie you should
watch it you know uh on a repeated basis
throughout your life
i presume you are not jewish as i am um
is that correct commander
i'm not jewish uh although
as you probably noticed the protagonist
of the apollo murders uh comes from a
lithuanian jewish family yes who was
your consultant how did you happen to
know about litvak as a term which 99 of
jews don't know uh litvak and uh
of jewish origin how did you come to
find that well the internet is a
tremendous resource i'm an intensely
curious guy
um i wanted a protagonist who had layers
and was complex and interesting and i
know a lot of people
you know that i i know people of many
faiths and and people of great technical
capability that can always just text her
phone so um so but yeah it made kaz
zamekas uh i think uh more nuanced and
interesting individual and obviously
he's
if there is going to be a series and
that's what i'm working on you know kaz
he needed to have a lot more depth than
just being a guy out of space flight i
loved it uh that was a nice little uh uh
you know little treat for people like me
um next up you call uh courtesy one of
the greatest skills or traits a good
astronaut has in your memoir uh uh
astronauts guide to life on earth what
do you mean by that courtesy why should
you be courteous you guys are you know a
team a highly oiled machine i've seen
michael jordan you know screaming scotty
pippen more times than i can imagine so
what does courtesy mean in the context
of being an astronaut
courtesy means putting someone else's
needs ahead of your own
by definition
you've done that because if you are in
service of the space agency or like a
lot of
my generation of astronauts in service
of your country for years before that
where you have said um
i am willing to die for the things that
we collectively believe in that that
is
the most courteous thing i think you
could ever say imagine if you walked up
to someone who was facing extreme danger
and you said
i am willing to die in your place
that's that's courteous courtesy but it
but it's you know at its absolute nth
limit and when you're on board a
spaceship putting everyone else's needs
ahead of your own the eating last
taking care of the stuff that's
important to you last making sure that
you are as productive a team as possible
i mean there are times where you have to
have a completely vertical command
structure you know where things are
going bad in a hurry i'm the boss we're
all doing this right now i don't care
what anybody thinks
but hardly ever is the spaceship uh on
fire you know
and so the rest the vast majority of the
time um thoughtfulness and courtesy and
other people's needs that's the way to
build a successful team and a suspect
successful
crew of space
explorers and a successful i think
mission through life
you're a pilot you're an aviator john
and martha king live here in san diego
famous educators
they talk about once you become a pilot
you're always a pilot there's a lot of
aviation geeking out stuff in this
wonderful book the apollo murders what's
in your dream hangar commander
i've been lucky enough to fly probably a
hundred different types of airplanes
some of them when i got fully pilot in
command um i've been fortunate to fly
the most powerful capable airplanes uh
the biggest c5 c141 747 and down to
single seat gliders
um and
but i think probably
my dream hanger has an f-86 saber and
the mark six with the um with the
leading edge slats and the big arenda
engine because that was a wonderful
expression of human freedom in three
dimensions and then another airplane
that i've flown which is uh a spitfire
and and uh i i've flown a spitfire a
bunch now too
and that's just an amazing design
especially when you consider that it was
designed in the 1930s you know look at
what cars were like and yet that
beautiful piece of machinery with that
magnificent rolls-royce rolls-royce
merlin engine but if it's my dream
hanger then i would also like uh
let's see i think a starship would be
nice elon musk's new vehicle if i'm
allowed to dream for this hangar i want
a ship that has the 100 reusable
capability to take us not just to orbit
but to the moon and back and we're right
in the cusp of proving that vehicle
right now yeah so yeah i'll take those
three for a start i'm hoping my past
guest jessica myer might set foot on the
moon and be the first woman to leave her
footprints there uh last rapid fire
question uh if you could be the first uh
astronaut to go to mars would that be on
your
on on the table for you
well sure but the astronauts don't just
go right
you know it's sort of like if you're a
pilot that's not just a job
if you're sitting next to someone on the
bus or whatever on the subway and you're
just having a conversation and someone
says oh what do you do i said oh i was
an astronaut all normal conversations
cease is from then on because you aren't
just an astronaut you know nine to five
or something
that's what you are for life it took
decades of your life in order to qualify
today and i don't mean like just a
tourist going for a ride but where it's
your profession where you've put in the
work and and earned the accolades um to
me that
uh
is
is you know uh
an amazing complicated and and
definitive part of it and so um to be
that astronaut uh to me is uh and to to
recognize that that's what you are for
life i think you know that's the reality
of it
past guest lord martin reece says when
he wants to talk to someone on an
airplane and they ask him what he does
he says i'm an astronomer when he when
he doesn't want to talk to them he says
i'm a mathematician so you could add you
know you could have you know lunar
geology specialist if you don't want to
talk to somebody okay final three
questions commander if you'll indulge me
at my forbearance here um
what would you put when you reach as you
know being an expert in lithuanian
judaism when you reach the biblical age
that moses reached of 120 years what do
you want to leave in your ethical will
not your material well what do you want
to leave to the millions of people who
are ideologically going to be influenced
to you by you what wisdom or learnings
based on your sojourn on planet earth
would you
bequeath
um i think
the absolute necessity to be grateful
to recognize you didn't give birth to
yourself you didn't suckle yourself
you didn't educate yourself
uh you didn't build the system that
exists around you you didn't build this
planet you are the lucky recipient of an
inconceivably long chain of history that
went before you and you're only here for
four score and ten or whatever your
particular lifespan's going to be
and stop getting so overwhelmed by your
own sense of importance that you can
hold up a sign that says the earth is
ending or like people have been doing
forever just to try and feel slightly
more significant have some grace
and have some gratitude for all that
have gone before respect them and
and with that uh honor them
wonderful second question harkening back
to arthur c clarke's 2001 there are
these monoliths that appear in the
opening scene these primates are hitting
it with a bone and later it's in space
on the moon it might represent clark
wasn't clear if it's a if it's a time
capsule if it's a warning if it's a
token of our existence or an alien
species existence first of all rapid
fire you believe alien intelligent
aliens exist commander
the odds are overwhelming that we're not
alone but we have zero evidence of life
anywhere besides earth so it doesn't
matter what i believe but the odds are
overwhelming that we're not alone we
just haven't found any evidence yet you
talk about the harsh climates on the
moon surface not climate you talk about
the harsh environment on the moon
surface in this in this novel talk about
what you would put on a monolith
guaranteed to last for a billion years
or more
well i think i'd want to know people to
know where we were in our journey of
self-discovery and technological
capability and i'd also wanted to maybe
if they hadn't come across it to be
something they could use so i think
i would put on our latest plans for what
a fusion reactor would how that would
work where you can generate power uh in
basically in an unlimited way in a
non-polluting way that that is going to
be such an incredible change to life on
earth when we get a fusion reactor
working and so and if we'd had that 500
years ago at any time in human history
it would have been revolutionary it
would have avoided you know so much of
the energy driven problems that we face
right now so i think i would put
all of the plans we have right now the
best ones possible for fusion reactors i
think that would be a useful
eternal gift not fission because there's
i've heard there's some radioactive
material on the moon surface so we're
not going to get into that or on mars
perhaps you mentioned mars as well last
question commander
uh now we're going to go backwards in
time we've gone forwards in time 120
years and a billion years last question
involves sir arthur c clarke's so-called
third law
he said the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible is to venture a
little way past them into the impossible
and that's the name of this podcast
i want to ask you what mysterious aspect
of life perplexed you or maybe stymied
you as a 20 year old
and that now you'd give him the advice
to help him have the courage to do as
you've done to go into the impossible
what advice would you give to your
former self
first off i got to spend a day with
arthur c clarke as his personal guide at
the kennedy space center i took him out
to the launch pad we stood underneath
one of the space shuttles that was
pointed at the universe and i got to
trade not just you know my own accolades
for him but some of his personal stories
of why he made certain certain decisions
in his life and uh
it was one of my treasured days because
he's such a creative writer but also a
scientific force of a guy but i think
um
the puzzlement over what is death
what does it mean
and it's it can be so fear-inducing and
my best i i've come from a violent
professions as a fighter pilot as a test
pilot test pilots die all the time we
just expect it in society there are some
roles that have a high fatality high
mortality rate uh and then many of my
astronaut friends have died pursuing
what they thought was important and
early on death terrified me and
overwhelmed me
um and my my best friend died you know
flying an f-18 on squadron
i did everything i could think of to try
and find ways to come to terms with it
but eventually
obviously i never solved it but i did
find ways to come to terms with it
personally and
and it's it's not scar tissue but it's
sort of like that you know where you've
been deeply wounded but you're still
alive and and your body
develops sort of healing around it and
when it happens the next time it does
it's not any less poignant you just have
a slightly improved way to deal with it
and it it allowed me to readdress life i
think
um
what should i prioritize
you know life can be so unforgivingly
short so live your life accordingly but
hopefully there's a pretty good chance
i'll make it all the way up to 90 or 100
and live my life accordingly as well and
honor the memory of so many of my
friends that died young in pursuit of
the things that i've been pursuing and
that they found worthwhile you know
those folks
if i have any regrets in life or or any
things that i miss it's them because
they didn't get to live the full life
that they deserved and so i try and lead
my life
both recognizing that it is finite and
that's okay
um but also to honor the the men and
women that uh that didn't get to lead a
full life to me that's a really
important eternal lesson and and it
drives so much of human behavior is that
fundamental unspoken fear of death and
how we all manifest our activities to
deal with it it's one worth confronting
as early as possible in your life so
that then you can lead the rest of your
life with grace
commander thank you for being so honest
and vulnerable and and just a delight to
talk to your hero of many of us here
happy thanksgiving to you up there in
the 51st state just kidding just kidding
we love canadians um and it's been just
a true honor to discuss this wonderful
book here in the states it'll be
halloween soon so the apollo murders
hold it up hold it up if you would get a
copy you will not regret it you won't be
able to put it down or as i found i had
to listen to it over and over again the
audiobook again is is just a work of art
as is the book i hope can't wait for the
sequel if there is a sequel i hope
you'll come back on the show commander
chris hadfield the one and only the
space odyssey did you ever oddity did
you ever meet david bowie last quick
question uh yeah we chatted back and
forth i never met him in person
unfortunately although uh i have toured
with his band and performed in multiple
cities and maybe when covid truly
settles down i'll have a chance to tour
with bowie's man some more and that's
great because it's like the people that
loved him his family of 40 years so i i
got to know him a little bit and every
every interaction with him was just as
good as you'd hoped it would be david
bowie squadron uh that would be
wonderful commander thank you so much
sorry we went over but it was too too
delightful to resist have a wonderful
day and best of luck with your wonderful
book sir take care and lovely to speak
with you thanks and thank you everybody
enjoy the apollo murders enjoy it you
will
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed this episode with
commander chris hadfield if you did
please check out nicole stott's new
fascinating memoir back to earth and
otherwise check out my other videos on
youtube and don't forget to subscribe
leave a comment in the comment section
would you like to go to space and be the
first person on mars
[Music]